die verbleibende rest opposition in der
türkei fordert das referendum zu
annullieren
und auch die oecd beobachter sprechen
von unregelmäßigkeiten was einfach viel
schöner klingt als wahlbetrug
die kollegin wird schneider hat den
sonntag für uns in istanbul beobachtet
wirte wie viel beschiss war denn da im
spiel
also erstmal natürlich handwerklich
extrem gut gemachte beschiss 51 4% viele
diktatoren gewinn mit 98 irgendwas ist
glaubt keine sau aber 51 4
da könnte man fast denken das war eine
richtige wahl
respekt wer so viel schon die wahlzettel
er wird ja in weiß sauber frisch dagegen
die hier seite baby kag brown aber
entscheidend war natürlich was anderes
als medienpräsenz von morgens bis abends
auf allen kanälen
der präsident macht auch selbst
programmhinweise
heute abend bin ich bei n-tv 19 uhr 30
und ihr schreitet hoffentlich alle es
sei denn ihr wollt im knast landen neben
demichelis noch eine zelle frei die nein
kampagne kam in den medien praktisch
nicht vor
nur rd das türkische tv programm vom
wahlsonntag ab wechsel früh etwas morgen
mit döner halali
da es immer nur erdogan zu gast dann
eine alte folge von was guckst du
erdogan was denn sonst
gefolgt wurde hart aber fair dogan
journalisten wollen sich autogramme von
präsidenten und danach komme die bei
schultern so gemacht
die lieblingswitze der einseitigen
berichterstattung ist es ja ganz schön
knapp geworden muss man sagen ja das
haben die akp leute während der wahl
auch gemerkt und dann hat die
wahlkommission geschlossen
wir zählen auch wahlzettel die gar nicht
offiziell abgestempelt waren
nachträglich schon wieder ja ich hatten
laufen immer noch fünf kilo jahr stellen
mit über zwei millionen stimmen haben
die so noch geerntet
die waren so kreativ unter der ja seite
waren so starke magneten die den
wahlständen super da freu mich schon
wenn die türken demnächst abstimmen ob
die todesstrafe kommt oliver kahns aber
was völlig falsch verstanden
beim nächsten referendum geht es doch
nicht darum ob die todesstrafe kommt
sondern sie hier
da kann man dann ankreuzen strick oder
gewähr
immerhin wird
[Applaus]